but I want to start here in the United
States I want to start here in New York
because it's hitting Us close to home
ABC news reports for businesses NYC
indoor vaccine mandate means safety and
headaches the Mandate improves safety
but poses operational and economic
challenges no it doesn't
so I made a series of phone calls the
first phone call I made today because uh
for those aren't familiar the mayor
signed an executive order yesterday
issuing the vaccine mandate with no
medical exemptions none if you have
cancer if you have MS if you're
immunocompromised and your doctor says I
can't advise this you can't get it you
are excluded from society in New York so
I called the city I said that can't be
right I read the law no exemptions but
if you're a famous musician or performer
you are allowed to go into these venues
to perform and do your normal business
if you work for one of these people you
are welcome to come inside these
businesses and do whatever you want you
can hang out have a drink all you got to
do is play one little song
so I called the city and said certainly
this must be a mistake I called the
local 311 line which is non-emergency
City Communications I did this on
purpose I I it's there's no number to
call the mayor's office but of course
you might get a political answer I want
to know the advice they're giving to
small businesses I want to know the
advice they're giving to residents of
the city who call because they
specifically say if you have questions
about the vaccine mandate call this
number press one or press two
a woman answered I said I was just
curious about if the vaccine mandates
for restaurants have a medical exemption
for someone whose doctor won't allow
them to get the vaccine no
um so ma'am you're saying that uh you
know if somebody's told by their doctor
they can't get it they can't go to any
of these restaurants or gyms or clubs
nope and I was like there's really no
medical exceptions and she says there's
some but not for that I can uh let me
put you on hold and see if I can you
know ask someone to clarify and they put
me on hold then she comes back and says
yup yup sorry if your doctor doesn't
allow you get the vaccine you can't go
either you have the pass or you don't so
then I called two uh law firms dealing
with human rights law and boy were they
quick to say no we will not advise buy
and hung up one of them uh the first one
I called they said we do deal with
medical discrimination we are not going
to advise on this we are getting
hundreds of calls for people we will not
be dealing with it have a nice day thank
you and I was like all right thanks
appreciate it bye the next one I called
I said I was curious uh I have some
questions about medical exemptions for
the vaccine mandate and if that's
written a lot I'm sorry we're not going
to be advising on any of that as per
discrimination have a nice day by click
wow started calling restaurants I called
like 25 or so and I would say all but
one said yes we are checking or we are
we are going to begin and know people
who have medical issues are not allowed
to enter the building and then the
scariest thing was the people who all
said look we're just following the
orders of the mayor uh you know the
mayor has deemed this to be what we have
to do and so we have to do it and you
know it's interesting because one one
restaurant I just I just got fed up and
I said I've been calling restaurant
after restaurant trying to figure out
where my friend can come eat and they'll
say the same thing isn't this a
violation of the of of human rights law
in New York City and then someone else a
guy picks up the phone and goes bye and
hangs up on me that's New York City
that's happening now in this country
granted
it's very different in Texas and Florida
what's going on but in New York wow
so I have some some questions for those
who would still service this city for
those musicians and entertainers who
would still be going into New York to
perform knowing that they are exempt but
they're going to require all of the
people who come to see you follow this
minute now first and foremost I got no
issue with vaccines at all I think you
go to your doctor you figure out what
makes sense for you my problem is
they're turning people into second-class
citizens who have done nothing wrong my
problem is people should have a right to
choose what makes sense for their health
not a despotic mayor who won't even
carve out medical exemptions this has
gone way too far in my opinion and I
think it plays into uh
I don't know the chaos and the crisis in
this country which is leading to
collapse because you're going to have
you already do Texas and Florida
outright being like we're not doing this
South Dakota we're not doing this but
then you look at the Pacific Northwest
you look at New York you look at San
Francisco they're also doing vaccine
mandates
what next
oh I look this is this is bad
but it also shows the magic of
federalism because you're right in Texas
you're free in Florida you're free in at
least some places in California you're
free if not officially then simply
because people just aren't playing along
look I think that leftists should get
leftism
really really hard
and this is it you look if you're in New
York and you vote for a Bill de Blasio
this is what you're voting for
so freaking enjoy it
enjoy it party on Wayne this is you did
this you you did this just like if you
voted for Joe Biden you did what's going
on in Kabul oh yeah chose it you made a
conscious decision I don't want Mean
Tweets I can't stand those Mean Tweets
nope I'm gonna vote for whatever
pseudo-marxus twit appears on my ballot
you just enjoy this is the issue I mean
the economy I love bringing this up
because it's one of the clearest
examples is how would you rate the
economy right now uh it's disastrous
oling shows that Democrat voters think
it's good
because these people don't know don't
care don't pay attention and maybe
that's why they vote for de Blasio
that's why they vote for for uh Joe
Biden that's why they're still voting in
another Democrat in New York City I
think you're assuming that this is a
reasoned thought process that is if I
vote for a Democrat good things are
going to happen no no no then I'm
showing a cultural solidarity that is my
point okay how could you possibly think
the economy is good right now yeah you
don't you've got a lot but you can't
very well say the economy is terrible
but I'm going to vote against the guy
who could bring us a better economy
because I don't like his tweets cult
exactly you know what else I noticed
when I was looking I was looking on an
anti-cult almost no it's literally a
cult I mean these people are uh they're
authoritarians they follow Dogma they
don't care about you could you could
have one day they say do X the next they
say do y and they say yes and it's like
you look at their Twitter histories like
how is this possible every other day
they're contradicting themselves but
then but for that to matter they'd have
to believe in something other than right
now it drives us crazy because we at
some level and this is a weapon they use
against us
still Embrace rational thought we we
apply facts and evidence and then try
and come to a conclusion I mean we just
naturally do that but they freed
themselves of that Tim they are not
bound by evidence or facts or your puny
laws they are purely called about power
it's it's it's about making sure that
everyone adheres to the authority yes
pure what we are seeing right now with
uh that's the priority big business
government it's fascism it is
Mussolini's fascism it is all about
power it is all about you will obey me
but it doesn't make any sense doesn't
matter not the Sense part
that's a side issue it's about power
it's about making sure that what we say
goes and that you knuckle dragging Jesus
gun people will bend to our will I
noticed something else when I was I
pulled up Google Maps and I was looking
at the different areas of New York and I
I looked in each Borough I was thinking
you know let's see how they're it's all
basically the same no matter where they
are no matter whether the person had an
accent or you know a North American
dialect or whatever they all basically
said the same thing but I noticed
something else
a bunch of the restaurants that I used
to go to are closed
a bunch of the restaurants that I used
to go to no longer open before dinner
and that to me was something really
crazy I was like wait a minute I used to
go there for lunch they're not open for
lunch now open till 5 p.m now yeah I've
seen them the businesses have been
crushed and you know it was really funny
many of the phone calls I made the
people I spoke to were so desperate
you can still sit outside it's okay and
I said I'm not gonna make my friend said
no no it's fine finally wait wait the
outdoor seating is beautiful it's
comfortable I was like I'm not sitting
outside no no no listen listen please I
was like thank you and have a nice day
probably about five other phone calls I
made they were that desperate they've
probably their businesses are probably
in shambles but you know what
I've said it over and over again get
away from these cities stop supporting
these people and how many people just
don't care and that's why I'll say it
again to the people who are going to
there look that we have friends of the
show who are still in New York many
dozens and they're still servicing the
city they're still paying taxes and they
sit there and they go well this sucks
and I'm like why are you still there
at this point you are actively
legitimizing the fascism in this city by
being a part of it by funding it and by
putting your talent into their broken
system will these people stand in
principle how many people do we know
that have been on the show have said
something like we don't agree with the
vaccine mandates and we won't stand for
it but I will absolutely run my business
in New York City and stay there and
allow them to keep doing this
legitimizing it
I mean you could say the same thing
about being an American citizen that we
just by being American we're
legitimizing the fascist militant you
know industrial complex but part of
being in the United States and following
this law this rule of law is that we can
change the government by as we're there
so being in New York you can change New
York's government no let's let's talk
about the people who don't live there
but go there for shows to make money
it's like performers yes people people
oh yeah Marilyn Monroe would refuse to
perform at racist uh places in like the
60s unless they would let the black
performers come in the front door sounds
quite reasonable right so we need more
performers like that right now yeah I
mean I I believe Eric Clapton's doing
that in England he just he just won't
play if you're going to force people to
vaccinate right and again I I love
whenever whenever I point out the
vaccine issue you should I am against
mandating vaccines there you Annie
vaxter well I'm not very good at it
because I had the stupid thing I wish I
could unhave it just to tell these
people to go to hell but you went to a
doctor I I consulted with my doctor I
looked at all the facts in my situation
my life of people around me and I made
my own decision as it should be as I
should be and I don't I don't care if
you have a vaccine I don't care if you
don't do or don't you know better than I
do and that's that is the essence of
leftism I know better than you do okay
but here's the important Point outside
of all that the requirement is actually
an ID requirement
you are now required to have a physical
ID to enter any indoor establishment
except for residencies and schools
pre-through pre-k through 12. how about
a polling place
you know I don't think we're there we're
there yet to where they can say it but
I'll tell you this some polling places
are in residential buildings
they may have to uh issue guidance on
that yeah it's uh or
some uh uh uh I don't know if they're
gonna do them in schools I remember when
I was in New York during I think it was
a mayoral election years and years ago
um I I one of the polling places was
like a residency it was a big apartment
building and then in the lobby they had
it or something like that I don't know I
think that's what it was so uh but
residencies are are Exempted oh well I I
don't need your ID for that well you
know I look I was informed by all the
smart people who are my moral Bettors
that uh it was the most racist thing in
the history of racism to demand an ID
before someone voted because of course
voting is the most important thing there
is
except when it comes to securing it so I
gotta say I'm confused thanks for
checking out this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episode codes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time